loto de mario fait du bruit
il la laisse à son mécanicien et fellow
bureau en matinée le mécano trouve le
bobo il évalue la réparation à 200
dollars mario accepte mais quand il
retourne chercher loto le montant de la
réparation a grimpé 400 dollars le
mécanicien explique qu'il a dû changer
une pièce de plus mario aurait aimé le
savoir et la loi de la protection du
consommateur lui donnent raison
chaque réparation supplémentaire doit
être autorisée parce que le coût réel de
la réparation ne doit pas dépasser celui
de l'évaluation écrite ou vernal bref
son mécanicien aurait dû lui rappeler
dans la journée comme il n'a pas
respecté la loi
mario peut porter plainte à l'opc et le
poursuivre si mario vivait en ontario le
coût total pourrait dépenser
l'évaluation mais pas de plus de 10%
le fin mot de l'histoire l'évaluation a
été dépassé et vous n'avez pas été
avisée vous avez la loi de votre côté